chips are magnificent creatures of the
sea built designed for deep waters of
the ocean
but once you bring these magnificent
creatures to inland waters around the
world they get fairly clumsy
the ship and sea made travel 3,000 miles
in a straight line but the difficulty
happens when you get to port and that's
when the ship pilot takes over these
essentially like a valet who parked your
car the pilot comes out usually on a
small pilot boat and then they climb up
the side of the ship on a small ladder
up to the wheelhouse to get the ship
into the port if it floats we are
capable of moving it
here at MPI we train ship pilots to
guide the largest moving objects on the
planet we have traditional classroom
training we have a state-of-the-art ship
simulator and then we have manned model
although these models may look like toy
boats they're actually precise tools
used to mimic the behavior of vessels if
you took a full-size vessel and shrunk
it down 25 times you can get very
reliable results a human being on the
our models would be like an inch and 3/4
Tom the man models there between 24,000
and 30,000 pounds of weight and they
have 0.4 horsepower they've behaved
exactly like a ship
this is real this is how it's done on
board all the ships around the world
starboard 10 degrees we surely would not
want to practice with a perfectly good
ship and say well captain we have to
drop anchors and simulate broke down
engines and steering so we do that with
these vessels it's a profession that I
think for me at the top of the maritime
field it's an awesome responsibility and
very challenging when I finished and
walk down a dock look back at the ship
and say yes that was a good challenge